3703 to write a clear for takeoff g'nite
three to right-click the takeoff
Malaysian 370 thank you hi in the four
weeks since Malaysian Airlines flight
mh370 took off from kuala lumper and
vanished on the way to beijing we've
been given a lot of ifs buts and maybes
about the fate of the plane and the 239
people on board I Malaysian 370 climb
platinum or 120 Leighton 370 climb five
double 120 so with the help of this
simulator an experienced former be a
pilot let's assess what we really no
well the facts are that Malaysian 370
took off from Kuala Lumpur airport
runway 32 right did a normal standard
instrument departure climbed up over the
male age in mainland up to flight level
350 which is 35,000 feet and then did
the handover call for Vietnamese control
ho chi minh city and that was the last
call they made palasian three sub zero
contact 120 according to military radar
we also know that for some reason the
aircraft deviated from its planned
course we know that the aircraft turned
left at the border between vietnamese
airspace and malaysian air space so if
we do that now what would we have to do
Jamaica right to make that happen I
would turn the heading background press
the heading select button and the
aircraft would start to turn as you can
see now
so it would have turned left onto this
sort of heading west early and we also
know at some point either immediately
before that or at about the same time
the transponder and the ACARS the
communication unit we disabled somehow
some way by something well yes that's
that's correct they stopped transmitting
so the ACARS boxes normally positioned
here and then the transponder which is
here and somehow it was switched off now
if you want to change your transponder
code to a mayday code you would turn
this button here if by any chance you
turn this one here in error you're
switching it off we know the jet emitted
a series of so-called electronic
handshakes pings picked up by satellite
and that from them and the radar plot
the airliner was probably headed for the
Indian Ocean off the Western Australian
coast was shimming here the aircraft was
no longer being controlled by the pilots
or alternatively was deliberately and
maliciously would say being controlled
well let's go with the format which it
wasn't being controlled they've turned
the heading round on a reciprocal to
head back towards kuala lumpur and then
passed out for one reason or another one
can speculate that may have been the
pressurization problem might have been a
small copy of far oxygen bottle
exploding there are a few reasons why
that could happen now if that was the
case the aircraft would continue in the
autopilot as it's doing now at its
current level and at its current speed
and that would then continue to fly
until such time as a fuel run out a
Malaysian 370 climb flight level 350 so
the best guess is that the wreckage is
somewhere in this vast suede of Indian
Ocean but the question remains will it
ever be found there still hope that the
flight recorders the so-called black box
will be discovered before its batteries
run out in the next few days
maybe then we'll find out what actually
did happen on the flight deck of mh370
almost a month ago good night Malaysian
370 Debbie Bowden Sky News